hello and welcome to this video playing
Pookie 73
hmm Bishop c5 is not yeah this is
actually this has a very questionable
reputation but I recently saw that it is
somewhat playable so I'm going to I'm
going to try it out
it looks it looks strange still look
strange I have a hard time really
accepting that this could be okay
looks so odd to put it here but I saw
some quite good players going into this
line so I'm going to give it a try
yeah I would like to play Bishop g4 95
so not a problem god Bishop f5 okay
hmm so how do we play this him cover
this
you
[Music]
yeah let's go I need I mean I don't need
but I probably want to this is strange
really
once your spawn to f4
response your responders weird if he
lost this simply okay
this is this assume this is interesting
94 is a bishop cakes and 94 is okay of
course but 94 is actually quite
interesting here 94 Knight takes pawn
tags and threatening f3
yeah components that's very annoying and
if he if he has to go Quinn to do one
nano I can take with the pawn which is
weird but f3 f3
it's just isn't that just basically
killing him
Bishop takes Queen takes Knight moves f3
is just winning and Bishop takes Queen
takes f3 I take on c3 was check this is
an important point
but scam oh boy I mean I don't I don't
see him defending this pollution that
would be surprising relief
he's got all this
stuck on the Queen side and I'm
attacking I'm attacking with the whole
army let's get the knight on to the
white king MK Bishop three
retina queen g-form okay it takes takes
Quincy for right enjoy
and premium with us actually it's either
works as a sacrifice or just as a good
move
[Music]
Kim now that that was there was a weird
sequence I mean the the odd thing is
like here yeah this looks perfectly okay
yeah for white I actually think he one
is a bit mysterious I wasn't quite sure
what this was about but okay anyway it
doesn't look bad I went f5 and then he
reacted with the
we should be - it's just not it's just
not addressing a 5 at all mean my idea
is clearly f42 soft enough this this
pawn and make this bishop better on a 7
and you play this away from the action
it's just a very strange move yeah so h3
is what the engine is recommending the
main point being that this is not an
option hmm yeah so I would have actually
had to take unless there is some miracle
move but I don't don't believe so take
take
and now this is an entirely different
story I can still do this but now the
bishop is still on this pawn so I'm not
threatening anything and in fact this f4
looks quite dubious they're giving white
even more scope on the light square so
that doesn't really feel all that right
I would rather play rupee eight or
something if that is possible and then
then try to do something there but this
is a better for white there's no
question about it
I mean again I was not super happy with
that fire but it should be too it's just
totally totally wrong just wrong f4 and
now white has to go to damage control
and after you fall it's probably over
Bishop d1 is not exactly an easy move to
play and Queen d2 also doesn't look
great
yeah but you have to do it you just have
to do it after this I think he's getting
killed and I mean clearly this is a
strategically fine position with this
whole world that my knight occupies so
nicely but 94 I merely is stronger it's
probably winning him I think it should
win it since the thing is if he go was
here yeah I can transpose to this
position that we looked at a second ago
but this is better
yeah because now he's in an eternal
pinned like here and he cannot get out
of this just impossible
age three this is this is a world now I
got rook F 6 and and this cannot defend
us + still this is fantastic fantastic
piece now um which is one consequence of
playing e4 of course I did it gives this
bishop a fantastic diagonal and here I
thought pawn takes wins the engine
disagrees
it says Bishop takes wins yeah I mean
that absolutely sure that it is a great
whole black yeah honestly the computers
of course right here if you look at this
the same thing applies I don't even need
that temple but I still believe it
should be winning Bishop takes Queen
takes h3 given by the comp Queen Queen
to h5 looks more logical action and then
this and it's supposed to not win yeah I
know it probably should winner if you
give it more calculation time that a
tech looks looks winning f3 FG - yeah
after this one that's probably it's a
merely game over
oh yeah this was this was made of course
but this is not not better threatening
made threatening this this is just too
much okay guys thanks for watching